hi everyone and welcome to technics and
sorry for techniques and practices for
testing angular I'm Adam Stephenson I'm
a solution architect at SSW I specialize
in building large enterprise web
applications and I'm lucky I've been
building angular and not dotnet core
applications since they're both in early
beta in Brisbane and been really lucky
over the last couple of years to just
pretty much only do the new angular
stuff and I spend about half my time
writing code for clients and traveling
and the other half of my time traveling
around talking about it and teaching
which is really fun because that's where
you really learn because you get to see
what everyone else is doing so hopefully
we can share some of that experience
with you today around testing so you're
going to hear us say angular 2 but what
we really mean to say is just angular
because the angular team would like it
if everyone stops using the version
numbers in the naming because it's been
quite confusing and we're currently at
angular 4 and soon we're going to be
probably next month we might be at
angular 5 so the idea is that it's going
to be evergreen a bit kind of like
Chrome I think we're at sixty because I
think I'm getting some touch bar
features for my macbook for Chrome in
version 60 I'm not sure yet but just
like chrome you don't really know the
number angular is going to be the same
so if you're talking about angular the
first version you should be saying
angularjs and if you're talking about
the second version or four or five or
whatever comes after that then it's just
angular so you'll see us try our best
just to say angular so who here in the
room hands nice and high is tested
angularjs okay cool probably close to
half the room that's good and who has
done any testing with the new angular
okay so if you have hands and so
probably a third of the room so you're
all in the right place we're gonna be
talking about all the new stuff that's
in the new testing utilities for angular
so in 1979 was the first time that debug
that testing was actually differentiated
as a different practice to debugging in
1996 we got XP and which had a real
focus on testing in 1998 we got s unit F
by Kent Beck
which was the unit testing framework for
small talk which is the first of the
xunit frameworks which is you know
really what a lot of our current testing
is still based upon in 2001 we got
jeaious unit from pivotal labs and
there's worth taking a note of them they
pop up a fair bit and that was the
JavaScript implementation of s unit we
got 2,000 in 2003 we got TDD and in 2006
we got behavior driven design by day and
North was like an extension of TDD with
human readable tests and in 2006 we got
selenium for doing outrunning out in
doing tests and in 2010 we got Jasmine
from pivotal labs again which was the
updated version of jeaious unit in 2010
we got angular 1 which is the first time
I had a framework or in the yeah was the
first time that we had a framework where
the hello world was actually unit tested
which I was really excited about because
from the very first day angular 1 had a
real focus on testing which was
excellent we got 20 in 2011 we got karma
from Google whose original name was
testacular and I really wish they'd have
stuck with that because I think that's
pretty cool in 2013 we got protractor
for running our angular end-to-end tests
which uses selenium under the covers and
in 2016 we've got angular 2 now I find
the history of testing really
interesting because when you look back
over it we're using protractor which
uses selenium under the covers we're
still running our unit tests in karma
we're still writing them in Jasmine
Jasmine uses BDD we're still encouraging
TDD like the tools that we're using in
the practices that we're using they're
not new and this is by far the best
coverage of we seen in any room of
testing and we asked exactly the same
question in January this year in London
and two people had done angular 1
testing and no one had done any angular
2 testing and so fought so it's always
been a struggle to get people to do
testing and I think that's because it's
traditionally been hard and front-end
testing has been harder than back in
testing and that's
we're here to talk about today is we
think that angular's made it a lot
easier the the tools and the frameworks
that angular has given us have made
front int us testing much more easy and
that's all we're gonna cover today so
the agenda we're going to talk about the
tools that we've got for testing we're
gonna have a look at jasmine we're gonna
talk about faking dependencies we're
gonna look at the testbed API and we're
gonna talk around the challenges around
testing asynchronous code with the async
and fake async methods and then we can
look at into in tests so let's jump in
and talk about some of the common tools
that people use for testing with angular
but it's important to remember like Adam
said that testing is not an afterthought
for angular you know it's it's been
baked into the system from the ground up
and so much so if you go actually go to
print out the documentation on angular
do it's 99 pages long so it's actually a
fair bit and that's just how to kind of
use it not sort of best practices as
well and that's I only know that because
Adam actually likes to print out
documentation and read it which is kind
of strange bit so it's a there's a lot
of information around and there's two
main types of tests that people do with
their angular code the first is unit
tests where you're just testing a small
function or a small piece of section of
your application and then you've got
into n tests which are completely
different where you actually run the
entire application in the browser and
then you query the Dom in the browser
and select elements and run tests
against what they've got the tools at
the moment that are the most popular is
karma as a test Runner and then using
jasmine as the testing framework for the
syntax and the assertions and all of the
matches and all of the different spying
and faking utilities that you get but
angular is also a big part of those
testing utilities especially in the next
version of it the very angular 2 or 4 or
5 and there's lots of different testing
helpers we're going to go through when
you're doing it into n tests then you've
got protractor is the main tool for
running it into n tests but a lot of
people are using jasmine as their
testing framework on top of that so the
syntax is very familiar across the to
there's other ones you can use if you
are used to using say mocker and sign-on
you could do that and more frequently
I've seen people wanting to use jest
and I've really enjoyed using just for
running tests because they're much much
faster and also running an ode you don't
have to worry and you see I process
about having chrome setup and other
sorts of things but that's still you're
still way out on the fringes if you're
using just with your angular by far and
away it's almost like 99% of people
using jasmine and karma and everyone's
using angular utilities so what does
Jasmine look like well if you look at an
individual JavaScript test they very
often look like this where you'd have an
it or a single speck or a test that some
of the words you'll hear and they will
take two arguments in the function the
first is a string which just describes
the individual tests and then it takes a
function as the second argument where
you actually do your tests and you can
see here we have a Jasmine matcher with
the dot two equal but there's a whole
bunch of other kind of helping matches
from the Jasmine library or oh yeah
library and then you would normally wrap
this test in a describe block which is
where you'd have a suite of tests so
inside this describe block which also
takes two arguments of a string
describing the set of tests and the
actual function that is where you put
all your tests so you might end up
having a couple of tests inside these
describe blocks and you often end up
nesting more described blocks inside of
this described block so if you were
testing say a logout function you might
have another described block just for
that logout function because you'll have
four tests around that one particular
function so it ends up being a nested
structure but that's the kind of the
basics so comas a test runner that runs
in the terminal and you can run it on
your CI processes and you'll get this
output like this in the terminal we'll
say it's executed say for example six of
six tests and most people tend to run
this on another screen just so they can
have some room and then you've got
protractor and that's very similar but
the way that it actually runs your test
is fundamentally different and we'll be
running some of these tests today so
here you can see it's running in the
terminal and it's showing kind of that
behavior driven development kind of
wording there so the the describe
blockers page colon joke page and then
the next part of it down here is the
individual tests running so one of my
other favorite testing tools is Duncan
is such a fanboy of wallaby that he
actually got them to make stickers
wallaby stickers in the world I actually
have a whole bunch of them here if
anybody wants a wallaby sticker later
they can come get one but what the it
who's used wallaby who's heard of
wallaby oh yes so it's getting more
popular so it's a hundred bucks I'll
just get that out there every year
you've got to be into it but it's great
if you're riding lots of tests or there
you really value testing and then it can
be worth it so this is what it gives you
on the left-hand side of these tests
here you can see you've got a couple of
green and red dots so the red ones
failing over here and then on the other
side you can see that it is expected to
be three so what you'd get in the
terminal you get right here there's a
bunch of other benefits you get a lot of
test coverage tools and other sorts of
things but that's kind of the real big
bonus of using it angular CLI is also a
really important testing tool because it
comes with all the live they're testing
harness setup so rather than having to
go set up all of these tools and get
them to work together you can just turn
on the CLI and run so it's a great way
to learn to test but it's also great for
client projects and real projects and we
we pretty much run the CLR and
everything we do so in summary for the
tools we think the CLI is awesome and
that you should be using it for most
projects and that karma and protractor
and Jasmine really are the default for
the community at the moment and that you
should check out wallaby jeaious that's
pretty cool and can help out and we'll
be using it a bunch today so you'll get
to see it so let's move on to talk about
jasmine for a second and let's jump in
and actually write some tests so we've
got this very simple application we're
gonna write some tests around today
it's a Chuck Norris jokes application
and you can click the button that shows
the next joke and the reason I like this
for showing testing is because it's it's
ink insanely simple to understand what
it's doing it's just a component and
you've got some button clicks which talk
to a component that talked to an angular
service that talked to a back-end and
then you've got to think about how do
you deal with all of those dependencies
and fake out the things that you want to
fake out and all talk about your choices
of how you do that so it's very simple
to understand but we'll talk about the
different practices you can use okay so
let's jump over into the idea and let's
actually run a couple of tests if I come
over into Visual Studio code here you
can see that we have a very vanilla
angular CLI project that we've used to
make it and if we open up the source
folder we have this app folder and
inside of here we have a joke feature
and this joke feature just has a joke
component TS file a joke service and it
has a spec file and we'll show you more
of the joke component but I'm just going
to write some of the simplest test we
can in angular for now so if we open up
this dot spec dot CSV file and the build
tool is looking for anything that ends
in dot spec TS so that's how it knows to
run Carmen knows to run these files when
you ask to run your unit tests so if I
give us a bit more room here I'm going
to come in and write a describe block
and I'm going to say that we're going to
be testing a suite of tests here so the
name I'm going to give we're going to be
testing a component here and we're going
to be testing the joke component and
then down in here I can do an individual
it block and or just a test and I'm
going to start off with something very
simple and say that it should add one
plus one here and then down in here I
can do a Jasmine expectation and I can
say that I expect one plus one equal
three so of course this is going to fail
and I can open up the terminal at the
bottom and I can run ng to get a hold of
the angular CLI and then just run test
and it's going to kick off karma and
Karma's going to build our app and run
our tests so in this case we expect it
to fail and sometimes I don't mind these
sort of sanity tests in my application
because when you've got lots of
dependencies to configure and lots of
services to fake and other sorts of
things sometimes a simple test like this
can be nice just to see that it's
running and you've got all your
dependencies lined up so down here you
can see that it executed one of one
tests and it failed this is your default
experience with the CLI and it expected
to to equal three so I could come up
here and fix this and then it will just
rerun because it's comments watching by
default it'll watch the file save
because I'm automatically saving in
Visual Studio code and then it's saying
one of one successful so I'm gonna kill
this now kill the terminal and I'm just
going to push command shift equals to
open the Wallaby shortcuts and then push
start so now we'll just run the rest of
the demo with wallaby but pretty much
it's doing the same thing it's just
running your tests but it gives you a
feedback right now and in the IDE
straightaway and you can get it for like
visual studio and web pack and a bunch
of not web pack crossing over here a web
storm there's a whole bunch of different
ideas that works for so if I change this
to be equal to three
you'll see
will fail and show you the thing there
and then if I change it back it'll rerun
and it's quite fast it's usually faster
than your experience with running Jazmin
and karma but it feels a little bit as
fast as Jess which is super fast so I'm
going to come down and write the world's
simplest angular test now so I'm going
to do another it block here I'm going to
say that it should have a title of let's
say Chuck Norris jokes here
Chuck Norris jokes and just going to
copy this so we can test against it so
down in here I'm going to have a
constant here for our component
component and this is going to be equal
to a new joke component and this joke
component has a dependency on the joke
service so I'm going to get this red
squiggly here because it's saying oh you
got to pass in something for this
dependency in the constructor of the
joke service we need to talk a whole
bunch about this but for now I'm just
going to shortcut it and pass in null so
I just want to write a really simple
test I'm just going to test the title on
the page or actually the title of the
property in the class of the component
nothing to do with the HTML template yet
so in here then I can do another Jasmine
expectation I'm just going to say that I
expect my component title and I really
love this every day I still get off on
it because we got typescript in our unit
tests which is great compared to what we
used to be doing so I get all this good
intellisense so I expect my component
title is going to be equal to the string
of Chuck Norris jokes and it looks like
wallabies frozen up I'm just going to
restart that and rerun it so then you
can see down here it's passing it's
showing me at ran it in two milliseconds
but if I make this fail here we can see
that it it's failing and showing us the
message on the side here so that's go to
the simplest way you can run an angular
test and I still really like that if I
don't have to deal with the HTML and
I've just got a really simple service
but you'll see us get into more
complicated tests now as we move forward
so we had a quick look at how we can
just use the syntax here and we had a
look at how we can just new up a
component or service but we'll talk more
about other ways to make your
dependencies for your tests so in
summary jasmine really is the default
still for the angular community in terms
of your testing framework
and it's more than syntax so you know
there's a lot of helping functions and
fakes and spies and sorts of things like
that which we'll show you now awesome
can I just get can I switch over from
the hand hill to this one because I'm as
I'm coding the hint this one's going to
be much easier if that's okay awesome
excellent okay so we're going to talk
about faking dependency so the faking
and setup of dependencies is still one
of the hardest parts of testing so it
doesn't matter what testing you've been
doing what whether it's back in testing
or front-end testing if you're trying to
test a unit of code and that code has a
lot of dependencies managing the those
dependencies and testing around those
dependencies is one of the greatest
challenges and we have that a lot when
we're testing our our angular
applications so we're always injecting
services so this is how this is the code
that Duncan had we had were
instantiating a joke component he was
just passing in null but to be able to
do any real kind of tests we need to be
able to work with that service so what's
a very common pattern is that we'd go
and create a fake object we'd create our
own object we'd put a function onto that
object and it would return something
that we knew so that then when we're
asserting against our component against
its behavior when we can expect what
that dependencies behavior is going to
be so we then we take that fake that we
created and we pass it into our service
and we can run our tests an alternative
method to creating your own fakes is to
use Jasmine spies so what we can do with
the Jasmine spy is that we can take an
object pass it in and then we can put
behavior or override behavior on that
object so in this case we're taking a
joke service and we're saying let's get
the get joke method and let's attribute
this particular behavior so it's going
to return a value and the value it's
going to return is an observable to fake
joke now why spies are great is they let
you intercept any function call so you
can use your real service and intercept
the function calls and you can override
the behavior of that function
what's really great about spies is they
also let you check the interaction
between your class or your component and
the dependencies so we can check to see
whether the joke service whether that
joke method was actually called we can
check how many times it was called and
we can even check what parameters were
actually pass to that get joke method
let's go and have a look at what that
might look like in code so I'm gonna
create a new test and the test that I'm
going to create is it should set the
joke property when initialized so let's
go and just jump in and have a bit of
our look at our joint component so when
our joke component is initialized mg on
in it executes and we execute the get
joke method the get joke method calls
our joke service cause it's Jack get
joke method and it takes the observable
that it returns and then map's it into
this joke property on our component so
what I want to do is I want to check
when the components initialized this
joke gets set the joke property gets set
so I could come down here and I could
come in and like Duncan's done I could
just come and instantiate a new
component but what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna lean on jasmine a little bit and
I'm gonna use its before each
functionality so that I don't have to in
every single test actually have to
instantiate a new component so I'm going
to come up here and create declare my
component at the component and I'm gonna
say it's gonna be a whoops joke
component and then I'm going to use our
before each to say when I come in say
that my component is equal to a new joke
component and just like Duncan did for
the moment I'm gonna pass him null and
now because I've done that I can come
and remove the instantiation of my
component from out of the test and
Duncan's test will still pass okay so I
don't need to do that now down in my
test so our test we're looking to set
the joke property when it's initialized
so I want to come in here and I on my
component I want to call the ng on
method which is what happens when it's
initialized and then I want to do an
assertion and I'm going to expect that
the components joke property is equal to
something that I know so fake
something okay now how am I going to do
that I'm going to inject a dependency
into my joke component for my service so
I'm going to come up and I'm going to
create a fake joke service fake joke
service and I'm going to say just my
fake joke service can be in any so now
in Y before reach I'm going to say that
my thanked joke service is an object and
on my object I'm going to come in here
and I'm going to put a get joke method
on it and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say it returns an observable of
fake joke now I don't know I do I need
to come up here and import of I'm just
because it's a test I'm going to import
the rxjs kitchen-sink obviously wouldn't
do that
oops in my actual application so now
I've got the off keyword and now what
I've done now that I've got this service
I can inject it into my component and I
know what that service is going to do
what I call the get joke method so I can
come down here I can see that Wallabies
already telling me that it's going to
work because now I can check and I can
say like my joke the the joke on the
component I'm going to expect to be what
I passed into it so that's using a fake
object I could come in here and instead
of doing that what I'm gonna do is use a
Jasmine spy so instead of creating my
own object I'm going to come in here and
say that the fake joke service is equal
to jasmine dot create spy object and I'm
gonna pass in my fake joke service
and then I'm gonna pass in an array and
that array is the is the methods that I
want to specify on that fake joke
service I'm gonna pass then get joke and
now I can attribute the behavior that I
want on to that get joke method so I can
come in and go fake joke service get
joke and tell it what I want to do I
want to return a value and the value
that I want to return is an observable
of fake joke and if everything lines up
my test is passing again so there's two
ways of doing the same thing I created
an object and passed in a fake object
and then I created a Jasmin spy now
what's nice about the Jasmin spy is I
can come down here and remember I can I
can check how my component is
interacting with that service so I can
come down here and I can say expect that
my fake joke services get joke method
has been called okay so it so I can now
check that interaction of my component
under test with its dependency so if I
don't cut if I don't call the method by
not calling on in it it's going to give
me an error I can even come down here
and check how many times it's been
called
so was it called three times No
was it only called one time oops yes
pretty cool so we're getting a lot of
extra power out of using Jasmine spies
so we had a look at injecting a fake
object and then we had a look at the
benefits of using Jasmine spies so the
nice thing about faking is they're
isolated I'm actually going and creating
an object that just has the behavior
that I need there's a few downsides you
can end up with a lot of duplicated code
and you can up and end up in the
situation where someone goes and updates
the behavior of the service and they
don't update the testing the tests
around it so you can end up shipping
something into production where all of
the testing is working but it's actually
not running in production because the
tests haven't been updated the benefits
of spying is that you've got the spying
functionality and assertions and you end
up with cleaner code so it's important
to know that I've given you two
strategies and two different tools and
you need to have both of them on your
tool belt both of them you'll need in
different circumstances and the faking
and setting up of dependencies is still
one of the hardest parts of unit testing
which is convenient cuz that's where
we're up to so let's talk about the
testbed API because that's one of the
newer parts in angular at the moment so
we're gonna talk about a few different
types of tests now because the test beds
help us solve a different type of test
so we've been writing these isolated
tests were just testing the properties
and the methods on a class or it could
be a component or a service and we have
no HTML template involved whereas in the
community there's this concept now
people talking about shallow tests where
you're testing not only the components
class but also interacting with the HTML
template that's involved and being able
to select the HTML template query say an
element on there and check its value
then run detect changes and do some work
with the test and then see if things
have changed there's also integrated
tests where you're testing more of the
app more components at once or the
entire application but we're just going
to look at isolated and shallow tests
today so we're going to use this testbed
the main thing you're gonna use it for
is configuring your tests so you can
come in and say testbed configure
testing module and being a hint in the
name there it sets up a module for you
and if you've done any angular it's just
like an angular module and you can pass
in all the parts of what a normal
angular module need and being an angular
module what it does is it says for this
section of my code these are all the
dependencies for it to be able to run so
for this set of tests these are all the
dependencies for this set of tests to
run and it's one of the pains in the
butt of doing front-end testing and
setting up all your dependencies so this
can really help so the first thing we
have here is imports and that is all of
the other modules you depend on so we
have HTTP dependency in our joke service
so I'm just bringing an HTTP module
I have declarations and that just
another fancy word for components so we
have the joke component which is what
we're testing and then we have providers
and that's where you register your
services your angular services so we're
registering our joke service here so
once we have this testbed it gives us a
hold of this fixture and that's kind of
the second main reason you want to use
test that is to be able to get a hold of
HTML templates not just because it's
super easy to set up dependencies so you
also you can use the testbed to set up
your dependencies for a service which
has no template but this testbed create
component and then passing in the Joe
component gives us this fixture once we
have this fixture we can get the
component itself again which means we've
got the properties and methods
accessible but we can get this debug
element and it's this fixture debug
element we can use to query the HTML
template associated with the tests and
we can do a bunch of other things like
run fixture dot detect changes so that
after you do some things in your test it
will then go and update the change
detection so the things are bound to the
page again that you've done in your
tests so we can say fixture dot debug
element query and we can query by CSS so
any CSS selectors you used to using you
can use them here to be able to query
the Dom to grab whatever you want so in
this example I'm grabbing the paragraph
element and I can call dot native
element if I'm running in a browser
environment to be able to interact with
that P tag as if I am in the browser so
this is going to give me all the browser
specific API
this area for this P tag so the test but
it's really great because it can it can
really help make a testing module and
give you this kind of system for
building up all your dependencies for
your tests because it gets much more
complicated than this when you have six
dependencies or six services and two or
three components and a button and the
router and HTTP and all sorts of things
you can query the HTML templates with it
you can run detect changes and you can
do a whole bunch more so it tends to be
the go-to for most of your tests but if
I can I still like to just and you up
the class if it's if it's something
simple so let's jump over and actually
configure our current tests to use the
testbed and run a test against the HTML
template and do a couple of different
tests in that way so I'm going to jump
back over and I'm going to take a little
bit of pleasure in getting rid of Adams
tests maybe I'm enhancing them okay so
we're gonna say that we want to have
this fixture property but we're going to
initialize it down below so I'm going to
say let fixture of type component
fixture and the type of component
fixture is going to be the joke
component and then underneath here we're
going to need to get a handle on the
component as well and this is going to
be of type joke component and then we're
also going to get a handle on the the
almost did company there and joke
service here so we want a property for
the joke service and that's going to be
of type joke service so if you've done
much testing you probably going war wait
a second you're passing in the real
service here this is a decision point
for all of your teams how value do you
want to get out of your front-end
testing so I'm gonna pass in the real
service here but make sure that I'm
going to intercept it and I never
actually call the real back-end that the
service can and if I had more time that
I would also fake out the HTTP section
so I really can't stuff up and call the
backend but for now we're just going to
intercept all requests out to this
service with the spy but I like this
because one it's easier to configure but
two it's giving me a little bit of more
and this is my personal opinion it's not
black and white and it's not right and
wrong because then if someone changes
this joke services methods and
properties now my tests will break as
well because I'm actually
interacting against the real joke
service so this is definitely something
your team is going to need to decide on
what flavor do you like to do do you
want to test more of it and get a bit
more kind of integration sort of testing
in a unit test but for now that's what
we're going to do so I'm going to come
down here and I'm going to get the test
bed and I can call configure testing
module on it and that takes in an object
and the first thing we're going to do is
imports which is an array and we're
going to pass in the HTTP module and
then we will get declarations and that
is also an array and we only have joke
component in this example and then we
have our providers so you saw this
before and this is going to be the joke
service that we want to register with
angular inside of these providers so
once I have this I can use this test bed
to initialize all those properties above
so I want to get this fixture because I
want to interact with the HTML template
so I'm going to say fixture is going to
be equal to the test bed create a
component for me in the component I want
you to make please test bed is this joke
component and with that I can start
using this fixture for lots of things so
next up I want to get the component and
I'm going to initialize that with this
fixture and I'm going to say hey fixture
can you please give me a handle on the
component instance and then also I'm
going to use this test bed to get a hold
of some dependency injection so this is
a different way to doing dependency
injection in angular than you are
angular than before so I can say that I
have this joke service and it's going to
be equal to the test bed dot get and
there's a whole bunch of different
helpers on this test bed this is just
one of them and I want to get an
instance of the joke service so I'm
going to ask it to inject that joke
service so it's available in my test but
now I've actually got the real service
so I've got to be careful with what I do
here and I've deleted Adams service I'm
also going to delete his test here just
for fun and I'm gonna come in here and
make another test so I'm going to say in
this one not now I'm not saying we
should initialize the property we should
have the HTML template with the text
actually on that template so in here as
they should have a joke bound
[Music]
bound to the template so inside of here
I'm going to need to show you another
way that you can use a spy same exact
same thing just a different syntax so
I'm going to spy on here the company
service so sorry joke service I can hear
some people helping me out here
we just ran a 2-day workshop where
everything was about companies so I
apologize
so just switching entities in my brain
so joke service here and I want to spy
on the get joke method and then I can go
down here and say and dot and we'll see
all the different things that are
available on a spy so I could call a
fake or call through but in this case I
want to return a single value so what I
want to return here is going to be an
observable dot of the string of the joke
so for now let's just say something
that's not looking like a joke like fake
joke and then underneath here what's
happened is we've just instantiated this
joke component and we've gone and make
this request and the spies intercepted
and given back this fake joke but that's
changes so we have to actually run
detect fixture dot detects changes here
so the HTML template will update so I'm
going to come in here and use this
fixture again and say here that I want
to save fixture detect changes and
execute that so now the HTML template
will be updated with that fake joke
string and then down in here I can set
up a constant joke paragraph element and
it's this joke paragraph element I'm
going to use from the actual HTML so
here I can say fixture oops
fixture the debug element query and I am
query by dot CSS and the CSS I'm going
to query by is this P tag and then I
want to get ahold of the native element
of that so I'm going to need to import
by from platform
- browser so this is the browser based
thing and then down underneath here I'm
going to do a Jasmine expectation I'm
going to expect that my joke paragraph
dot text content content is going to be
equal to the string of
fake jokes let's just see if this will
fail first done a whole bunch juice I'm
actually just going to restart all of
you for a second and that should kick
back in and say you're expecting fate to
equal fake jokes so let's just finish
that off and now our tests passing so
that's pretty cool we're actually
grabbing the HTML template and checking
the P tag so of course this is going to
be more brittle and now you're more
invested in keeping up to date something
that's married to the template as well
but that's quite powerful so we had a
look at how we can set up the test bed
in the before each and how it can be
much easier to actually set up all your
dependencies because when you do a lot
of angular you're making modules all the
time so it's the way you used to doing
it and then we were able to use a debug
element to query by that P tag so it's a
pretty big API there's lots of things
you can do it at this test bed so it
takes a bit of time to learn and get
comfortable with but it's well worth it
use it in all your tests and it helps
you make basically an NG module to set
up your two dependencies and then it
runs everything in a zone and if you're
a little bit like me the very first time
I heard the word zone I'm like what a
zone so I'm gonna pass it over to Adam
and he's going to talk about signs
awesome so I'm going to talk around the
challenge and talk about the challenges
around testing asynchronous code because
asynchronous code eggs codes complexity
to writing your JavaScript unit tests if
you've got you know it's quite simple to
have a form with a button on it the
button calls a service the service makes
a HTTP request which would turn
something and then when you're doing
your tests you want to assert that is
all about working together but the
challenges around that asynchrony so
luckily so how we've been doing that in
the past is with jasmine done callbacks
and they work by using a promise and
then calling done the downside of
jasmine done callbacks as they require
chaining promises handling errors and
then calling done explicitly and while
we don't actually really recommend them
or like using them that much we still
need to use them sometimes around some
edge cases what we've got now which
makes life a lot more fun is the a is
the async method and the fake async
and really the key to them is zones does
anyone want to try to scribing zones no
okay
so Zames zones aren't difficult I just
think they're a little misunderstood
okay so here's the textbook definition
is that zones defined and executors
define an execution context for
asynchronous operations so what happens
when you're executing your asynchronous
code in angular is it executed within a
zone so whenever you kick off an
asynchronous operation like a button
click what happens is a mod is a micro
task is put on a queue when that when
that task completes the micro task is
taken off the queue and why that's
really powerful is angular's aware of
when there's outstanding asynchronous
operations now when we come to testing
it gets even better so we've got the
async and the fake async keywords and
what happens is when you wrap your tests
in the async keyword they're now going
to execute inside a inside a testing
zone so what happens now is when I do
something like do a button click in the
testing zone I'm putting a micro task on
the queue and I can now use fixture dot
when stable to know when all of the
micro tasks have taken off the queue and
all of the asynchronous operations have
completed so it's going to make our
testing much easier so when we're
writing a fixed it up when stable
resolves when all pending asynchronous
activities within the test completes so
it makes it much easier for testing
async in our angular apps now this fake
async and fake async is similar to async
but we use instead of using when stable
we actually use the tick method and tick
simulates the passage of time until all
of the pending asynchronous requests are
complete alternatively you can specify a
number of milliseconds to to simulate
waiting ok so what's really nice about
fake async is instead of using result
waiting for when stable it's actually a
much more linear progression through
your test let's go and have a look at
what that might look like
now I'm gonna do a test and I what the
test I'm going to do is I'm going to say
it should get the get the next quote on
button click so Duncan's previous test
should have a joke the end of the page
said when the page is initialized we
should go out and get a joke from the
service and bind it to the page and
check that and that's that was nice but
I'm going to take it the next step and
I'm gonna say let's do that but when the
buttons clicked it should go and get
another joke and it should bind that to
the page and I want to test that as well
now Duncan keeps deleting all my code
but I'm more of a copy his code and
still it kind of a guy so I'm gonna take
the code off his previous test and then
I'm gonna go and make it better so what
he was doing was he was creating the spy
then he was doing a round of change
detection he was getting a handle on the
joke paragraph and checking the tax I'm
now gonna go and get a handle on the
button so I'm gonna I'm gonna create the
button I'm gonna say fixture debug
element and I'm gonna do a query by CSS
for a button and then I'm gonna get the
native element and what's really cool is
I can just go button dot click so I've
now simulated close I've now actually
clicked the button so what I'm going to
do now is I'm going to come in I'm gonna
need to do another round of change
detection so I'm going to do it detect
changes and now I'm going to do my
assertion and I'm gonna say that I want
my joke paragraphs text content to be
equal to something else
okay but at the moment my return value
is only returning a single value and I'm
going to go and query the service twice
what's with the page loads and once when
I hit the button so I'm gonna change
that to return values and then I'm gonna
come in here and put another value in
what I'd really like to be able to do is
come in here and go observable of fake
joke too and put a delay on it of say
two milliseconds because that would be a
cool test
to simulate waiting longer on the second
one I'm not gonna call it a bug but
let's say that there's still some work
going on to make that happen for me so
what I'm going to do instead is I'm
going to come in and I'm gonna do an
observable timer and I'm gonna say wait
2,000 milliseconds and then do a map and
what I'm gonna do after my map is then
I'm going to return fake joke - okay and
that'll do the same that'll do the same
thing so now the first time I request
something from the service it'll return
fake joke the second time it's going to
wait two seconds and then return fake
joke - now you can see here I'm having
some issues obviously so the buttons
getting clicked I'm doing detect changes
and I'm still getting the initial fake
joke because it's waiting two seconds to
send me the second message does that
make sense
so what I want to do is I want to take
control so I'm gonna wrap the whole test
in fake ASIC okay and that's going to
give me the ability to actually take a
whole word on there
I missed it
I think you put it on the very bottom
closing the hole
there we go it looks like the Kampala
was just ah no no I've taken it off all
you think it's waiting for me I try
again
the suspense suspense there we go that's
better I actually was put in the wrong
spot
okay awesome so now what I've done is
I've wrapped the whole method in fake
async and what wrapping the whole method
in fake async gives me the ability to do
is to come in here and go after I click
the button what I want to do is I want
to come and wait let's wait those let's
wait two seconds and see and I'll need
to import tick I'm getting back its now
it's so now it's simulate simulating
waiting the two seconds and now I'm
getting back what I would expect which
is fake joke - and my test is passing so
the fake async method lets me control
simulator time what's really cool is
that even though I haven't I'm just
going to call out even though I've got a
two-second wait it only took 30 seconds
- 36 milliseconds to execute the test
because fake async is working with
simulated time now I'm gonna show you a
very similar test I'm gonna do exactly
the same thing but I'm going to do it
with async instead of fake async so I'm
just gonna import async and remember I
said instead of using tick a the async
users fixtured dot when stable and I do
I'm gonna say then and what I'm going to
do is I'm going to move my detect
changes and my assertion up into when
stable
extra bracket oh not having luck with
brackets now am i there we go okay so
and I can't so I'm gonna use when stable
now because I'm using an async method
instead of tick and you'll see in a
second when it reloads that my test is
passing okay so it's doing the same
thing but now I don't have that linear
progression
the other interesting thing as you can
see my async test is actually using real
time so it's actually taking the field
two seconds to execute so we had a look
at using the async wrapper calling the
button click and then using fixture dot
when stable to resolve our async tests
as well as using fake async and using
the tick method the benefit of async is
it really does simplify coding our
asynchronous tests
I prefer fake async a lot of the time
because the tests appear to be
asynchronous the challenge with fake
async though is that there's some
situations where it doesn't work for
example you can't make xhr requests so
in summary testing is still writing
testing codes can still be a little edgy
and but the new helpers that we've got
around with async and fake async make
life a lot easier so these bits are cool
and we're looking at writing unit tests
but let's actually shift gear a little
bit now and let's actually write a
couple of end-to-end tests to finish up
so the intent tests ensure that
integrated components function is
expected so you've got to take that mind
shift of going what I'm really doing
here is running the entire up in the
browser I could not actually know that
it's angular in a way and then I'm
selecting things off the page and
checking that they're actually what
they're meant to be so usually they're
very different they run a lot slower
usually tend to run them when you're
checking in your code or when you're
actually writing them you don't let them
sit there spinning away like when you're
writing you or if you're going to be
doing test-driven development sort of
thing and usually you're testing more
users story where they login navigate to
a page click a button so it's a very
different motivation for these tests so
let's go write some very simple tests
around and to enter around the testing
the joke title and also around the joke
button so it's kind of similar to what
we did with our unit tests in a way so
if we jump back over to Visual Studio
code here I'm going to close this down
and just open back up Explorer here and
you can see at the very top we have this
e to e folder and that was put there by
the angular CLI and you get a default
test out-of-the-box I renamed it to be
jokey - E - spec PS but if we open this
up we can see here that it's empty and
the very first thing I'm going to need
to do is import a couple of helpers here
and I'm gonna get these from protractor
because that's what we use for writing
these tests so I want to get element and
so I can select some elements I want to
get by so I can actually do that CSS
selecting and I also want to get a
browser helper so I can navigate around
so then I need to make another describe
block so you can see what using jasmine
again so it feels very familiar
so here but my motivation is really
different now what I'm actually testing
is a page or a set of pages in a lot of
cases in this case we're testing the
joke page and I like to think about it
like a page versus a component because
I'll have lots of components on a page
normally so in this case down here I can
come down and make another individual
spec here and I'm going to say that it
should have a title of the similar sort
of thing here of Chuck Norris jokes and
I'm gonna grab that like we did before
just so we've got the same thing again
so down in here what I'll kick off by
saying hey browser can you go get to a
URL for me and I just want to go to the
base URL for application we actually
have no routing because it's a really
simple app just go load the page and
navigate to here and then what I want to
do next is I want to get a hold of our
title so I'm going to set a constant of
title and this is going to be equal to
element by dot CSS and I want to grab
the h1 element because that's what we've
got our title of our application in and
then once I've got a handle on that I'm
going to use the
text function to be able to actually get
the text so you can see the syntax is
slightly different here from protractor
for the helpers but it feels very very
similar then once I have this then I can
do a Jasmine expectation again and say
that I expect my title to equal the
Chuck Norris jokes here and missing the
quote on the end there now I don't have
any whiz-bang wallaby here to spin this
up and run really fast because that's
not what end-to-end tests do or how they
work I have to actually run this and it
fires up the browser so I'm going to
give us a bit of room and move this over
to come out of full screen and move this
over to the side here just get rid of
these and if you're very fast like
Superman you'll see when I run an NG
eatery down here in the terminal you'll
see it'll spin up the browser on the
side the default is going to be chrome
and it's going to navigate to the root
of the application and then it's going
to query by CSS for the h1 tag and then
see if it equals Chuck Norris jokes so
it spins up runs checks it doesn't seem
to be able to find it slow Superman and
we have an error so error is timeout
failure interesting let's kill that down
and let's actually run that one more
time so ng e to e and let me just glance
over this note you can do by CSS dot get
text and element title let's have one
we'll run it it looks down into the
terminal here I want to go
time for a cup of coffee runs now it
looks like it's stalling to query for it
and find it which is kind of interesting
I browser protractors felt right found
time out waiting to find it so
unfortunately my demo here for the last
demo of the day's failing on us but
we've been pretty lucky so far I don't
think we're going to want to watch me
debug a test live but some people might
go yeah this is where the action happens
this is the current page is not an
angular application
we are going to so we're going to take
questions straight after the talk
outside and if work out what the issue
is you can come and join him but you can
basically see the gist of how these
tests work here so you'll navigate to
the page you want to get and you'll use
these helpers to select queries off the
page and your one these tests so I think
most likely my problem here with my test
is probably something to do with my
dependencies or something else here
versus the actual code in the screen
because I've run this a bunch of times
but if we move back here over to our
slides we did have a quick look at how
we can run a test and we use the similar
syntax here to actually and you can see
the exact code here so by dot CSS here
for the h1 and then we're expecting the
title to equal and you can also run
other tests so in this case here what
I'm doing is I'm navigating to the root
of the application and then I'm
selecting the first joke and then I'm
doing a button click and then selecting
the second joke and expecting that the
second joke will have been set onto the
page so you kind of end up doing a few
different things here in these
end-to-end tests that you do so in
summary they're not a unit test they run
in the browser and they usually test a
much more broader user story your
motives for writing you for an
end-to-end test they're going to be very
different than testing a function and
they help save a lot of manual testing
you imagine you can automate a lot of
this across multiple browsers and very
aggression testing and large code bases
they can be super invaluable and that
kind of leaves us with like our summary
of testing in our teams I guess is
testing something that the whole team
needs to practice and it's something
they need to practice regularly it's not
super difficult to do but if you're not
doing it regularly enough you tend to be
under pressure at work and you don't
want to jump in and write the test
because you're running out of time but
if you do practice regularly they're not
actually so difficult to to get in a
habit of doing a lot of so we also run a
lot of courses a lot of two days and
three day courses so we have a whole
much more than we cover now in our
course work so if you want to get that
for free you can use this coupon so you
can see we have a whole bunch of course
work that goes through using all the
things that we've demonstrated in more
so if you go to courses fire bootcamp
comm you can go to end
n-b-c - Sydney - 2017 is the coupon a
last for and you try and actually click
on the lesson and then you can put that
in that coupon and then you've got
access so I'll leave that open for a day
yeah so everything you want to get don't
forget Adams favorite color is green and
we love green so we had a look at the
tools that everybody's using today we
had a look at jasmine and being the
testing framework we looked at how we
can fake dependencies with Jasmine
spires we looked at the testbed API for
helping set up our tests we had a look
at async and fake async to help with
asynchrony in our tests and we had a
look at a couple of end-to-end tests
thank you very much guys this is our
twitter handles make sure if you say hi
if you see it's a real conference and
thank you very much
[Applause]